everyone uh i think we're gonna get
started right on time
uh and so our next speaker is uh ophir
nahum
and fear's gonna tell us about attacking
the off policy problem
with duality take it away of fear
hi thank you uh yeah so i'll be
uh like the rest of the talks today i'll
be talking about off policy
learning uh but unlike those previous
talks i'll be
uh discussing an approach based on
convex duality
so i'll just get it right into it and so
here's
the setting i'll focus on it's an mdp
where your policy is pi and it starts
each episode at some
initial state given by some initial
state distribution we use zero here
at each step it produces an action which
the environment uses
some reward function to turn into an
immediate reward
and then uses some transition function
to transition to a next state
and in the off policy setting we
typically only have access to historical
logged
experience data so we might have access
to
the things in blue but we don't have
explicit access to the things
in black whether it's the initial state
distribution or the transition open
world functions
but in this section in this setting we
still want to do some sort of
reinforcement building some sort of
policy evaluation policy optimization or
other things
and so the problem is how do we actually
do these things how we how do we do
reinforcement learning
in this policy setting and there's
a number of challenges presented by this
setting
in this talk i'll focus on two of them
uh which arguably i was sort of related
but for now i'll just
talk about them as two different
problems so the first one here
is the distribution shift problem which
refers to the fact
that the off policy data set you have
access to
uh was sampled or gives you a
distribution over state actions which is
different
from the on policy distribution you
usually want
when performing monte carlo samples or
when performing on policy policy
gradient
and then the second big challenge is
what i'll refer to as the generalization
problem and this refers to the fact that
in the policy setting
you necessarily have limited data uh or
your data
only covers a small subset of the state
and action space
and so this limited data must
exacerbates existing extrapolation and
generalization issues
in standard oel algorithms and this is
why we get uh
things like exploding q values and
divergence and training
and things like that
so in this talk i'll talk about how to
approach these two problems and
specifically i'll explain an approach
based on convict's geology so what i'll
start with is i'll start with
the lp so i'll show a linear program
where the primal lp corresponds to q
values of some policy
and the dual lp corresponds to d pi
which i use to denote the on policy
distribution
of pi and then what i'll show is that we
can actually
approach those two challenges i
mentioned using
convex regularizers and specifically
i'll show how the distribution shift
problem
can be approached by regularizing dual
variables
uh and analogously i'll show how the
generalization problem
can be attacked by legalizing the primal
variables of the slp
and then using a bunch of conviction
applications
to yield objectives which are
practical and applicable to off policy
stochastic settings
okay so let's get started so rl as an lp
so there's a bunch of lps you can use to
express
reinforcement learning problems in this
presentation i'll focus
on what i call the qlp uh which is a way
to express the value
of a policy uh which i had as this row
of pi function
as a linear program where you can see
why it's called the qrp because the
variables are q values
and the objective here is the expected
initial q values
so the expectation here is over state
samples from the initial state
distribution
and then initial actions sample from
your policy
so we have this objective uh and then
the constraints
are actually uh the the standard
development operator
we're used to with respect to policy pi
so the constraints say
at each state in action your q value
should be at least
the immediate reward plus gamma times
the average next q value
well i've used this t pi operator to
represent this expectation over next q
values
so this p pi is just uh you can think of
it as just the transition matrix under
policy pi
so we've got all these inequalities uh
and actually this
objective which is a minimum pushes
all the q values down and turns all
these inequalities at the optimum to
equalities
and once you get equalities here uh it's
easy to
figure that the q star should be exactly
q pi
the q values of pi and then when you
stick q pi
into this objective the average initial
q pi values
is exactly the policy value
so this is the qlp in its final form uh
and then naturally it has a dual foam
which yields the same result the policy
value
but in a different manner so you can see
instead of
q values now we have these d variables
which you can think of as a distribution
and the constraints are no longer the
standalone operator constraints we're
used to
instead the what's called the transpose
belmont operator
or you can think of them as flow
constraints and flow in the sense of
probability because these
equalities exactly express the
flow that the stationary distribution
of pi has to satisfy in order to
be aligned with the transition matrix of
pi
and so these equalities actually express
the concentration of flow of the
probability distribution on the
transition dynamics determined by pi
and so the the d variable has to be
exactly
d pi the on policy distribution
according to these constraints
and once you figure that d star has to
be b d pi
you can stick it into the subjective and
you get the sum of
d pi times r which is exactly the
expectation
under the on policy distribution of the
worlds which is your policy value again
so these lps are nice
but they they're not immediately useful
to us
and the reason is because of all those
constraints
so those constraints in either the
primal the dual a constraint for each
state in action
and these constraints are difficult to
handle in the
settings we're used to the off policy
settings we're used to
and so like i mentioned in the outline
what i'll describe
is how to apply contextuality to these
lps
so what we'll do is actually utilize
convex regularizers
uh apply them to these lps and then use
duality and that'll actually yield us a
more tractable
and unconstrained objective
and what i'll show you is that there's a
lot of choice in what
regularizer you use and that choice of
legalizer
uh ends up affecting what the what the
final objective is
and so picking the right legalizer is
key and makes the difference between
whether your final objective
is actually tractable in off-policy
stochastic settings or it's not
okay so with all that foundation laid i
can
get started on the meat of this
presentation
starting with distribution shift so at
the beginning of this
presentation i made this promise to you
that okay there's this big challenge
enough paul cll it's called distribution
shift uh
and we're gonna actually approach this
problem by regularizing the dual
variables
of our lp so now i can show you how
that's done
so we're going to legalize the dual
variable so i'll start with a dual lp
here it is expressing the value of
policy pi in terms of this
optimization over d
and now there's a lot of choice in how
we regularize this i'll just
uh reveal the choice that ends up
working well and
uh the legalizer we're gonna use is the
after versions
so we're gonna fix some reference
distribution
uh d superscript d uh and then the f
divergence of
d from that reference distribution is
some function
of d uh and that function will act as a
regularizer
on our dual lp
so what's important to note here is that
usually we think of legalizing within
f divergence as uh somehow
encouraging the the policy pi to be
close to a reference distribution
but in this case the regularization is
really just to
sort of make the duality work out
and actually you can figure that these
these constraints here
in a legalized problem there's a
constraint for each state in action
and there's also a variable for each
state in action and so the constraints
uniquely determine that
diesel has to be d pi regardless of
however we legalize the objective
okay so now that we've got this
regularized constraint problem
we can apply duality uh and when we
apply duality
uh like i promised we end up with an
unconstrained objective
so you can see now we're back in the
primal space
since uh the optimizing variables we're
using oh
in terms of q values the difference is
that
now constraints are penalties right if
you recall the primal qlp the final qlp
was essentially
this expected initial q values objective
and then these were constraints right
these these uh ended up being in the
inequality constraints
now instead of constraints we have
penalties
and the form of those penalties is comes
about from the form of the legalizer we
used
and conveniently the regularizer we use
this f divergence
from a reference density d superscript d
its dual form is the expectation over
that reference distribution
of f conjugate well this is just a
potential conjugate of whatever f
you chose here
and so there's a lot of choice in what
this reference distribution is
uh no matter almost no matter what
reference distribution we use
these basic steps will hold and the most
convenient reference distribution for us
is
exactly the off policy distribution we
have access to right if we just set
d superscript d to be the distribution
in our replay buffer
then this objective ends up being just
an objective for q
in terms of an expectation overall we
play buffalo which is very
convenient
and so now given this if we want to do
policy optimization
uh we can do it in an off policy way
like so right
we have an objective over q that's
has an off policy expectation and
represents the legalized value
of pi and mvp and then what we want to
do with pi is we just want to maximize
the circularized value so this is the
way to do
uh policy optimization and off policy
matter
you can algorithmically relate it to
q learning and active critic because
what we're doing here is we're also
optimizing
a q function to minimize some convex
function
of bending individuals the difference
from these standard algorithms is that
our loss for q is an off policy
expectation
whereas if you do q learning and actual
critic you can do an off policy
expectation but that's the result of
essentially just an approximation to an
on policy objective
here we don't have an approximation to
an on policy objective
this off policy expectation comes
directly from the
the the neat properties of using
contextuality and the fact that we use
that
after versions legalizer
so this is one way uh that
regularizing with a dual can approach
the distribution
shift issue but there's actually another
way that
another nice property that comes out
from this and it comes out
from the fact uh it can be brought up
when you think about
what's the gradient of this inner
objective with respect to
i uh so imagine like well we're actually
doing policy optimization
uh when we do policy optimization what
we would do
in the ideal scenario is first solve
this you know optimization get some q
style
and then for pi we'll need to take the
gradients of this objective with respect
to pi
so what is the gradient when when we
take the gradient
of this objective uh at some point we'll
have to handle this pi inside this
penalty function and so we'll do a chain
rule and the chain rule will give us
some term that looks like this right the
chain rule will give us
uh the density of d superscript t
and then the derivative of f star of the
residual
and then there will be some more terms
from the chain rule
now conveniently or perhaps obviously
this same expression is actually the
expression for d star so convex reality
tells you that
if you have q star if you've solved this
q
problem you actually have a solution to
your original problem
and that solution d star has exactly the
same expression
and if you recall that d star is exactly
d pi
and so when we do the chain rule
what happens is this off policy
expectation
implicitly turns into an on policy
expectation over dpi
right the off policy collection
naturally comes from the q star values
and so you get on policy policy gradient
from our policy data
and it's important to note that when you
actually implement this
in practice you don't need to think
about all this map that's going on
it's really just happening in the
background all you do is just
do back propagation as you're used to
and it's really just the fact of how you
train q that gives you this on policy
gradient implicitly
okay so that's the first half
of what i wanted to show and now the
second thing i promised you was with
respect to this generalization challenge
uh and the fact that if we legalize the
primal variables in the right way
that can be interpreted as approaching
the generalization problem
in off pulse cll so now i can show you
this
so we're in the final lp which looks
like this to remind ourselves
it's an lp over q values
and it might be interesting to think
about at a high level and a sort of
hand-wavy
way what does generalization actually
mean in this lp
so as i mentioned before in the off
policy setting we have a data set but it
doesn't cover
all our states and actions and so we can
imagine well what would happen to this
lp if we were missing a constraint
for a specific state in action well as i
mentioned at the beginning of this talk
this objective of initial q values
actually pushes
all the q values down and they'll
support it by these inequalities
and if one of those inequalities is
missing there's nothing to support that
q value
that q value is going to go to negative
infinity and then you're going to end up
with
an estimate of your value of your policy
which is negative infinity
so this is bad uh and you can imagine
it can always it can also blow up to
positive infinity
if you change up this min to a max
so how do we get away with this we need
some sort of legalization
and i'd argue that it's natural to
legalize
the primal variables by constraining
them to be in some function class
f uh which is inherently low dimensional
so for example we can take this function
class f to be
a unit ball and some reproducing kernel
hill those case
right and this way we don't have to have
for example a constraint
over all states and actions if we're
missing a constraint in some state in
action
as long as we have some constraints in
state and actions which are
similar to it then there'll still be
some support
holding this q value and keeping it from
blowing up to negative infinity
so this is the idealization i'm going to
use
i'm going to interrupt you for a second
to play three to four minutes left
okay thanks so here's the legalized
version of final right i've got the same
primal objective primal constraints but
then i've added this
uh penalty which essentially constrains
q to be
a bounded lkhs node
and like in the dual what we can do is
we can apply convex reality and end up
with an objective which is back in the
dual space it's in the dual space in the
sense that now we're optimizing
over this d distribution
but the difference is that the
constraints are now penalties
right the previous dual lp had this
objective
and then these were constraints and we
were constraining them to be exactly
zero
now because we had this context
legalizer the known constraint
the constraints you know dual are now in
the form of penalties
and that penalty is in the form of the
rkhs
null so we're really penalizing the dual
objective
with the constrained violations
as measured in an rkhs null
so we've got an unconstrained objective
but it's still a little
unwieldy with this rkhs gnome uh but
obviously there was a reason we chose an
arcade as gnome
uh and it's because we can apply uh the
kernel type
to this uh penalty and get a
nicer phone so specifically what happens
is you can imagine
you can interpret what's going on here
as you're really measuring the
mmd distance between d which is some
distribution
and then this transpose bellman operator
applied to d
which is some other distribution and so
you can write that
instead of some as a sum of expectations
of kernels
right well you have an expectation over
two samples from d
you have an expectation over two samples
from this transposed domino operator
and you have an expectation uh over
one sample from each of these
and now we have nice expectations and
though a bit more tractable than
optimizing this
directly so
clearly there's a choice in what can
only use uh
and i'm not gonna potentially know what
the best kernel is but
there's a lot of interesting choices for
example if you want to choose the energy
distance kernel
uh you get interesting expectations over
distances
of state action pairs uh and in this way
we can see that that original
legalizer we applied which whose
motivation was to
impose some sort of uh generalization
properties on the q values
shows up in this dual objective in the
sense that
this dual objective is now
representation of where
and the distances of states and actions
appear in this dual objective
but again good representation is key and
uh certainly those it's still a big open
question
what the ideal representation or what
the ideal kernel should be here
okay and then the last thing i wanted to
show you about this generalization
aspect is how to make it off policy
right so we've got
a nice representation of whale objective
for the dual
uh but all the expectations over these
uh
distributions were learning d and the
bellman
transfers operator applied to d but
it's pretty easy to make these all off
policy by just applying a change of
variables so
instead of optimizing over d you can
optimize
all those data we'll say that it's
defined as d divided by
your off voltage density
and then all these expectations nicely
and conveniently turn into our policy
expectations
right so now the d dot r term turns into
an off policy expectation of
o but weighted by zeta uh and then all
these expectations
turn into our faulty expectations of the
kernel but again weighted by zeta
and so this is a ends up being a fairly
practical
practical and tractable objective full
of policy settings
although there still is this annoying
squibble term but
usually you can hand weight that away as
well in practice
okay but that's all i wanted to show you
and as a summary
uh what i showed was the distribution
shift problem can be attacked by
localizing
the dual variables uh the generalization
problem in off-pulse ul can be arguably
attacked by legalizing the primal
variables
i've listed a small subset of
works which i think use these tricks
but certainly there's a lot of other
applications
uh to use these strikes and i think
there's a lot of
potential future work and well one how
to apply these
tricks which i've shown you and two
other other choices of legolas or those
which yield even better objectives or
better
uh resolving of these challenges
but that's it for me and i'll take any
questions
thank you so much for fear this is
fantastic and a beautiful compliment to
the morning's talk uh i believe that uh
we have a question from one uh gergey
noye to start
uh followed by a question by jacob
buckman so i'll start category today
go ahead yes that's right thank you mark
and thanks of your
i really love this work uh so i
have a question regarding uh your
regularization of the dual variables
so one issue that i see here is that
it may be actually difficult to get
unbiased estimates of the gradients
using only samples right because
your objective function is a next nested
expectation right it's an expectation of
a nonlinear function of a conditional
expectation
yeah yeah yeah i agree that's an issue
and
i i glossed over that issue yeah this is
this really is an expectation inside a
convex function uh
and yeah i think the the only
well the best way to get around that
that's known to me is just to
optimize the lagrangian instead of the
full convex dual
and when you optimize the lagoon you
also get the same nice properties like
you get the same
on policy policy gradient properly
right right so but
but does that really result in like a
practical algorithm in the end
for like large scale settings these
appeal parameterize
the dual variables yeah in practice
in my experience the using the
lagrangian
is complicates a lot of things in the
policy optimization setting
at the same time i'm hopeful that in my
experience has been
very short and i'm certainly not an
expert at
really scaling up the algorithm so i i
think it should be doable it's just
an operation so there's still work to be
done i guess definitely
i have a follow-up question for you a
few you have implemented this in
stochastic environments and it did
do something so that there's empirical
evidence that this is okay
yeah yeah in practice what we do is we
just
sort of eat the bias and or ignore it
and optimize this
objective as is and and that works
better than doing the right
unbiased thing
um right right thank you
any are any questions from uh maybe i'll
actually take the
q a question um there was a question by
jacob buckman
from earlier which might be actually
answered by the generalization point you
made but i'll ask
of here uh this exact formulation you
have here right now
uh won't it simply learn the optimal
policy for the empirical mdp
given by d d so how does this correct
from statistical error introduced by
finite samples
right so uh yeah so
my generations ignore the statistical
error issue um
what you can do well there are ways to
introduce statistical error like um well
one straightforward way is to think of
this as i mentioned this is just like an
mmd
right between d and the transverse
dominant operator applied to d
uh and there's lots of literature in the
kernel field about you have two
distributions you want to compute the
mmd but you only have finite samples
and how to get confidence bounds and
other things
based on that so i know that
issue in the presentation but it is
approachable by standard methods
fantastic um
i'll take maybe a life question if
there's one
okay let me ask matisse federico's
question which is
the restriction to some function class
made me think of the talk from emma
uh can you regularize by basically
having policies that have enough
coverage is that something you've looked
into
um
i hadn't thought about it before i guess
thinking about it now i guess the the
question of legalizing
in the policy space thinks makes me
think more of like
legalizing the dual variables uh
right in some sense like the
legalization on the dual variables with
the estrogens
uh he's a is a penalty form
that legalizes the policy to
be within the support um
but yeah i guess i guess you could
turn it into like a constraint on the
policy and
some other things and make it work out
and
have nice objections but yeah i hadn't
thought about it
properly yet in fact i think nanjiang is
going to jump in and tell us that there
is in fact a connection so maybe
yeah uh can can people hear me for sure
yeah hi hi aubry uh great talk so
actually i think i have some answer and
comments
question which is closely tied to all
the questions being asked
like so far so i think it's interesting
so so basically
uh we have realized that in our most
recent like paper
uh that algae diets actually in some
sense solve the problem that is
asked by um that is discussed by
like the talks earlier right when you
have when you don't have sufficient
coverage in data
so what's very nice is that if you look
at the algebras and
what happens when you don't have data
support
uh the the optimization oh actually it's
central algebras right so you add yet
another decision variable to uh
to model like marginalized importance
waste so in this cases
your optimization objective for a given
pi is precisely a
lower bound on the policy value of a
particular pie
where how loose the lower bound is
depends on how
good your data coverage is so we thought
that's
extremely promising so we actually
wanted to try to run the algorithm
in that setting but again like when you
have that additional decision variable
to model important ways
you get max pi max something like max pi
max q like main data or something and
holy [ __ ] i i just have no idea how to
like
optimize it and neither do we have any
like empirical success
and i want to take your mind on this
like do you think like
the optimization aspect of it is still
promising or
we just need to like look to something
else to solve this problem
uh so i think
i guess fixing the optimization directly
i think is
interesting to me uh i guess like
the few properties of the optimization
which we can point to as being
bad and maybe the sources of issues like
one issue is like this optimization over
pi
doesn't interact well with the q or zeta
because it's like
it's not like jointly convex in terms of
pi and q over things like that
uh and there might be
ways to approach this like instead of
using the qlp using the vlp directly
at the same time i'm not sure if these
issues were so
more theoretical are actually the source
of a lot of uh practical issues
so at the same time i feel like an
an interesting other approach to this
optimization problem is to perhaps take
the
a lot of the insights that come from
convex jolly
uh and a lot of the compelling
objectives
uh but instead see how we can get these
insights and compelling objectives
applied to
uh the existing and well performant
standard dynamic programming algorithms
and i'm not sure what's the best way to
do this but i think maybe
it should be feasible in the sense of
like can we take the insight of like
this on policy policy gradient property
uh in algae dyson and other things uh
and can we
apply it to dynamic programming without
having to
get into the optimization difficulties
endemic of
doing all these mins and maxes
okay fantastic well thank you fear just
uh
thank you again for the talk and uh so
this concludes in fact
the uh the talk portion of the day so
thank you again all the speakers